here is Robert
you know where he is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Panda
robert panda panda
[Music]
action show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
John
[Music]
jump
Nikki's typing now
bum said good
this thing is [ __ ]
yeah
he's got no case
baby with you
[Music]
are you
let me know it so I can go back over the
let me let me know when I can go back
over there
Marcus is that one that Reuters is
[Music]
the taxable
yeah you surprised
you got to go up they're taking you
there
[Music]
ladies listen up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the night before
[Music]
it was ask you to take
[Music]
[Music]
yeah they're filming Susan up walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
romantic
[Music]
was that
for what forgers it's
so they're gonna talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but in
[Music]
[Music]
three man
little hallway bumper leaving behind the
barrier
okay
[Music]
they can
you think
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
they're accidentally turned off the
light
[Music]
[Applause]
somebody : that way throughout
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
camera
[Applause]
you have perjurers but now and if we
miss any like did it sound from that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
yes on duty
[Music]
you want to be able to shutdown
[Applause]
I think they're gonna be able to that
side
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you hear me yes you did our on
morning welcome thank you for for being
here John Dunning Miriam Haley Jessica
man
Annabella Shore family will govern young
megan has Jones the losing or bone eight
women who have changed the course of
history in the fight against sexual
violence these are eight women old our
justice system into the 21st century by
declaring
it's rape and sexual assault and sexual
assault bill a matter it works great vis
rape whether it's committed by a
stranger in a dark alley or by an
intimate partner in a working
relationship
it's rape whether it's committed by an
indigent versus or a man of immense
power per Swedish privilege rape is rape
whether the survival reports within an
hour within a year perhaps no it's wait
despite the complicated dynamics of
power and consent after assault it's
rape even if there is no statistical
evidence and even long time ago this is
the new landscape for survivors of
sexual assault in America I believe and
this is a new day it's a good day
because Harvey Weinstein has finally
been held accountable for crimes he
committed the women who came forward
courageously and at great risk made that
happen
Wednesday is a vicious serial sexual
predator who used his power to threaten
rape assault some trick of humiliating
and silences victims he has been found
guilty of criminal sexual act in the
first degree and will face on that count
a state prison sentence of no less than
five years and
here's to the jurors the jurors for
their service and careful attention
their verdict turn the page in our
justice system
on them like Harvey Weinstein I want to
say thank you to the assistant district
attorneys paralegals and analysts who
worked on his space including the Maxine
Rosenthal
Kevin Wilson Shannon Goldberg and
rebellion on her window Alyssa Marino
Andy Clark dandy Mejia Cruz Stephanie
Mattel and Henry Hogan and especially to
Harry Galvan megan has and Joanne Uzi or
beau who conducted a terribly difficult
and meticulous investigation and
performed masterly a trial under the
greatest violence they finally to the
survivors of Harvey Weinstein I are and
we although an immense debt to you who
had the courage beyond measure to speak
your story to the world to this
courtroom at great personal risk and did
great personal pity so those of us who
were privileged to people courtroom when
they testified you know that these
survivors
brave they were heroic
words can't describe adequately the
sacrifices the survivors made to pursue
justice
weisstein with this manipulation his
resources his attorneys publicists and
his spies do everything he could to
silence the survivors but they refused
to decide they spoke from their hearts
and they were they were heard by ycs
other survivors and by sexual predators
all over the world sacrificed their
privacy and self-protection knowing
better than the extent of Weinstein's
power and manipulating retribution and
abuse so damn I would say you broke
silence to hold him accountable and
believe me when I say that because you
have done so a generation of sexual
assault survivors
how are you fully satisfied with this
were they for you feel in some way came
up short you just mentioned could be as
little as five years well I'm certainly
not dissatisfied by the brewery I think
this is a very difficult case very
challenging case in a case that really
moved our understanding of what sexual
assault is whoever can occur shattered
myths that I think have been part of the
criminal justice system for a long time
so I believe they'd be felony conviction
when they maxim about the twenty five
years is is it is not the top counts of
the indictment but by no means do I am I
disappointed with the jury's the
announced the statement that Harvey
Weinstein is guilty of sexual assault
and they any other questions some of the
women like Annabella Shore and Jessica
man it appears the jury for qt8 at their
testimony
do you many concerns that women are
going to have to endure such terrible
in court at the hands and lighting
lawyers well I think we're going to
Jessica man running light speed was
committed was convicted migrated from a
third degree rich Europe took great risk
and was in substantial hey that's funny
about what happened to her many years
ago
I can't look behind the jury's verdicts
or how they arrived at that we have to
respect that process but by no means is
in a statement against this URL or the
campaign in the g7 chord preparers by
the way through its and the solution
that they didn't leave adequately brings
them all together with the unanimous
verdict in terms of the
cross-examination I think we saw
cross-examination that the kinds that
we've seen for years and years and years
I hope that with this verdict
it will become obvious that those kinds
of attacks on survivors and victims when
they understand making it seem like it's
all their fault will be realized as
legal attacks that just simply are no
longer going to work in this day and age
as time that wears stop using them and
continuing the myths that I think the
jury verdict must have today which the
message the women about coming forward
because someone's question why
full of women who get elected first of
all I would say that dealing with this
was being ready this with a desperate I
hope that survivors will see that in
this justice system prosecutors judges
and juries even when the facts are not
simple and even the dynamics of the
relationships between the survivors and
the abuser are complicated so I think
Dean the message is this is a big day
this is only today and I hope women will
hopefully will understand the
significance of the jury verdicts today
in terms of the time it takes to report
sexual assault Dean we cannot put
ourselves in the shoes of a victim of
sexual assault to understand what is
going through his or her mind you heard
on the witness and the reasons why a
number of these women survivors did not
come forward they were definitely afraid
of our D Weinstein for one thing and
that he would ruin their career so
there's all sorts of dynamics that make
survivors of sexual assault not
comfortable to come forward however
those stories are now part of a part of
what we all know understand better after
this trial that survivors have to go
through so key and I think my hope is
with this verdict
survivors of sexual assault whether it's
a mr. Weinstein or whether it's of
someone else will come forward and our
office and others like our office will I
hope be there to listen to them and to
help therefore thank you guys thank you
so much everybody have a good day
Maur doctor and i so my life easily
destroyed and now I want to just feel
that that moment was worth it that all
those years that I lost no at least I
have the right of come so I just needed
to see this happen I wanted to put it
back in my mind you know
[Music]
now
[Music]
I have words for this person I don't
think he deserve
I just feel that
all other people that we've seen do
something like this I feel that he's the
example he was the person that
I
of course they were a pressure bye thank
you
and everything
the process
I guess it wasn't worth they came out
from everyone and so that's a part of
working all together
you're not here
he always said
because of course I know
having situation like this happening
again that's what I'm going to do
nineteen
what's your name excuse me
I am Villar
and to clarify but not evolve in this
case
[Music]
Cosmo
got it
[Music]
[Music]
just reacting
of course I'm super-happy
[Music]
yes
my story 15 I try
have to see that at least something
fifteen
the know it off I stayed worked with an
undercover operation with the police to
report him of being audited see me
I can say that right now I'm happy to
see most years that I lost for my life
are going bad of course there's a lot of
work
[Music]
being there
situations like this will never happen
yes
mrl Amer me but Ilana
I
[Music]
working with organizations that try to
and that would try to
window for essentially mutation so that
at all
right now
you know be all of their Jesus possible
just
then our life gets back
who was one of the three bono witnesses
in this criminal trial and I also
represent three other claimants and
civil trials civil cases against Harvey
Weinstein and I also represent two other
people who are objecting to the civil
settlement again toke week door and this
is my name is Debra Katz
I also represent
I've represented over and write certain
cider at the Weinstein but dog and I
both represent two very courageous women
who testified in court at great personal
risk they came forward
described the predatory behavior of now
convicted rapist Harvey Weinstein
no longer will we accept as a society
the defense
poor Harvey Weinstein was unwitting
victim of women who took it
will no longer be acceptable in courts
for anyone to argue that women were
victimized by sexual predators brought
it on themselves because they wanted to
advance in their careers
over
QT ation of that argument today and that
is all to the good that moves us all
forward because arguments of the Thai
faith I hardly watch these players have
hit women back and have silence women
and its care equipment from time
immemorial
is a new error
has educated us fall about her pervasive
this kind of behavior is and have
unacceptable
today the journey put an exclamation
point on that in the most significant
way plus
Doug and I were in port because we saw
party whines get me remember
Harvey Weinstein is exactly where he
should be now
Harvey Weinstein has heard dozens and
dozens of people by the sexual predatory
rapist violent behavior and today there
could be no other discussion other than
Harvey wants is exactly
let me just add to Deborah's comments
all of which I completely agree with
them I think one of the things about
today is we will not see Harvey
Weinstein come down those steps in his
feeble attempts of pretending to be
unwell and using a walker because he is
now in custody
he's been remanded he awaits sentencing
in March by Judge Burke and today is a
significant day because he's held and
held responsible for his actions but
while we can't undo that harm while he's
been convicted we can't undo the harm
that is caused to so many victims today
will be some mode of relief for all of
the assault survivors who hopefully
today can bring about some sense of
relief and so for all the survivors who
participated in this in criminal trial
I think Deborah and myself and everyone
else have participated in this trial
want to thank them and I'm confident
that each one of the six woman who
testified convinced this jury to convict
two separate victims one of criminal
sexual assault in the first degree me me
Haley and I know that Gloria Allred will
be speaking about Parrish shortly and
also another victim in rape third degree
is miss Beth
so to me me Haley Jessica man Annabella
are entirely we'll dumped on even Lord
young let me say on behalf of all the
victims thank you very much for your
participation thank you for having the
courage to stand up in not easy
circumstances to face cross-examination
to face the media to face scrutiny but
to do what was right and thank you to
those woman for lending a voice to those
that couldn't be directly heard because
we know that there are many other
victims of Harvey Weinstein who were not
testifying at this trial but their voice
was heard through these six courageous
women and of course we're also grateful
for the incredible the courageous
reporting that got us here through Jody
Meghan and Ronan into their sources who
risk violating non-disclosure agreements
rogue investigations threats and the
power of Harvey Weinstein we would not
be here today if it were not for that
report in for those sources and of
course we're also grateful to the
Manhattan district attorney's office
work tirelessly and reporting and
investigating and trying this case -
Jonah luzie - Megan past we're all
appreciative - go hard work dedication
commitment and seeing that justice was
served today and to the men and woman
who supported them in the district
attorney's office and decide that as
well he and I necessarily not
necessarily have gotten on back in 2011
with DSP when I represented not be South
to Diallo but today is a new day and to
him I congratulate him and I'd like to
thank him for bringing this case and
finally to the jurors the jurors who
gave up weeks of their life to be here
to finally come back with a verdict
and as they saved it then behind me -
defense counsel they had a job to do a
client to represent because of them
Harvey Weinstein received a fair trial
even though he was luck even though he
lost he was lucky enough to have them
represent them
let me just say this is fine finally
because I think we have some people who
really want to speak could serve to
speak but I represent three other woman
as I mentioned the circle Oh miss David
miss you it and we intend to continue to
hold Harvey Weinstein accountable for
what he did to those women and to follow
up on this criminal trial
thank you
Donna please come on I have it short
stick today the jury in the criminal
case of the people of the state of New
York versus Harvey Weinstein returned a
verdict against the defender get down
all right Harvey Weinstein about you
babe
do you want to go over there
is that what you want to do
[Music]
this is illegal reckoning for Harvey
Weinstein the three witnesses whom I
represent have been role models and
courage without them and their
willingness to testify under oath in
this case and without their willingness
to be subjected to an intense and brutal
cross-examination this result would
never happen
Amy Haley
mimimimi sacrificed her right to privacy
in the interests of justice
Anabella sure was a very brave witness
on this issue of sexually predatory
conduct
Lauren Maryam was a polynomial
prior bad act nation
he's also one of the two victims in
which will be prosecuted in
[Music]
all of my three clients should be
considered
here from the women's movement and the
victims right soon
these witnesses told their truth under
oath despite what many people felt were
unfair attacks on their credibility by
Harvey Weinstein's defense lawyers who
attempted to have to do anything and
everything legally pocket
to challenge the motives of the
witnesses and blame them for what the
witnesses testified that the defendant
Harvey Weinstein
fortunately the defense attempts to do
Scrat attempt were not successful
my clients bravely stood in their truth
and refused to be intimidated for
leaders shamed
substantially changing their testimony
about what the defendant
I'm very proud of them I'm very happy
that the jury
that was read in court today as to me me
the jury took their time they asked very
thoughtful question
and advances thank them for their
service
or the first arcane
carefully considered virgin
is a just result as to me me
Harvey Weinstein
now have to finally face the serious
consequence
here in New York on March 11
well serious charge is the one
convicted on from my client Mimi
the victim does have an opportunity
Kippur victim impact statement
and in the event that
good thank you that's good
in addition I look forward to seeing him
in Los Angeles
after the sentencing
itself against the criminal charge which
will face him there
as I said I represent our young he's one
the charges have been filed in Los
Angeles
the porridge of his sentencing and an
external trial in bus
you're as I said I'll be representing
[Music]
I will say this about Annabella
the jury did not mind
was guilty
and five against Jessica
and sexually predatory
Anabella
absolutely one of the bravest women I
know she sacrificed
investing so much time
so much
just for the cause of justice
[Music]
she didn't have to do it
[Music]
she did do it
and I just so honored to know her that
you represent her
the fact that they did
that there were members of the Kari
[Music]
have I heard and
interviews by members of
I have confidence that there were people
in the jury and remember
did dredit Annabella's testimony
it's just that the jury could not find
guilty on
without a fight
it's always possible that that she was
to leave
but that they require
[Music]
but nonetheless
she's so brave
the Anthony once said courage is the
best protection
and will also demonstrate courage in
testifying
I'll be happy to take some questions
maybe you could
how to voice their right
pardon me
100 wasted right now if I could talk to
Harvey why see what would I tell him
right now
well I just found that his attorney
[Music]
well he shouldn't have been surprised
if you do to women
what you did to me me but the jury found
that you did to me me
a little sexual act
but the jury found that you did to jest
but you shouldn't be surprised that you
have to fix criminal consequences for
the
committed against them shouldn't be shot
you should have been prepared for this
business as usual in the United States
this is the age of a powerful women
and you cannot intimidate them anymore
because women will not be silenced
they will speak up they will have their
voice
they will stand up and be subjected to
your small army of defense attorneys
cross-examining them attempting to
discredit them humiliate them shame them
and they will still stand in their truth
so Harvey Weinstein
this justice has been a long time coming
but finally here that is not the end
because la
is still going to receive
I believe that we have
[Music]
I'm sorry
in this case
[Music]
Prince Andrew
[Music]
start by talking
and so I do hope that
saw my message
the difference
in Great Britain even seven if you see
the
Plus
because it's about children for Jeffrey
ups
in a sex trafficking
well they have a question because he
hasn't agreed to be questioned
the clock is ticking
any other questions about Barbie
Weinstein
very happy
when the verdict came back guilty for
Bill Cosby
I said
where
come back guilty
I will say once again women were
believed so for those of you
we're listening and watching
if you are a victim of rape or sexual
abuse
or sexual assault
please know that this is a new day
law enforcement
is now getting
are beginning to believe you and to
convict
so just have courage
this is a new day
as well thank you
[Music]
[Music]
but I might kill right here okay how's
that all right
[Music]
everybody on the street please
thank you the sidewalk down
[Music]
[Music]
well I knew that
sticking around anyone else
like just one I couldn't
[Music]
there we go
sorry
sword
right
keep fighting
I mean we're definitely stands for
we sing
[Music]
I did just like a food
[Music]
yeah
I think it's
hey Kirk before they're take water you
can insert before
I've had so much
[Applause]
right
yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not yet
the physical there I'll save them here
are they getting stuff set out
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Consumer Cellular final approval
Callisto across Europe possible
consciously silicosis company's initial
Juna Georgia till colossal a polished
metal others